snow patrol what's going on you tell me
I'm guessing it's not a coincidence that
we're left here with nothing to do for
the next few hours hey everybody its
Charlie this is gonna be my icicle flash
episode video there were so many Easter
eggs and so many ice puns the ice puns
were over 9000 there's a new round of
that flash ring giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
a flash related comment on the video
I'll name a new winner at the end of
this but obviously spoiler warning for
the episode if you haven't seen it yet
so starting with number 10 we get a big
zoom shout out in jitters when cicadas
getting ready to kill that metahuman
measures them foreshadowing zoom coming
back during the 100th episode we learned
that the premise of that episode is that
berries gonna be traveling back in time
because he needs to get something to
fight cicada so that just explains the
mechanics of how they bring zoom back on
the TV show without him being the black
flash or him being dead because he was
killed at the end of season 3 the woman
that he takes down at the beginning of
the episode - is really more of a t1000
terminator reference just because she
turns her hands into giant blades like
the t1000 they make her Johnny Cage
reference from Mortal Kombat because of
his finishing move cisco makes a joke
about dr. Quinn Medicine Woman when he's
talking about Caitlin they made a Snow
Patrol reference but 9 they go to
Caitlin's father's lab and she's
reunited with him for the first time so
they remind you a little bit about his
backstory he supposedly had very severe
ALS so they don't know if he can move
but he's walking around like a normal
human and they play all this creepy
music in the background and they make a
reference about it being a very creepy
looking lab what kind of science do they
do here I have no idea he started to
notice some fishy things in the
background there's a special cryo
chamber he explains the mechanism by
which he cured his ALS in number 8
reveals that he's been in contact with
several cold base DC Comics villains
these past five years that the TV show
has been running so if it wasn't clear
he's been in this black ops site since
before season 1 he says that it was
actually Harrison wells that led him on
to it and helped hooked up the video
feed at STAR Labs so that he could watch
what was going on but not talked to them
so that means that the reverse-flash
version of Harrison wells sort of
engineered this scenario probably
because he comes from the future he
knows that he turns into icicle
eventually so he wanted to help bring
that about the same way that
reverse-flash wanted to create all those
metahumans when the particle accelerator
and off or at least he knew that he
would be creating them because he was
trying to create berry so that he would
become the flash and he could steal his
power to get back to the future so it
was just another way to tie one of the
big villains that they're introducing on
the show back to the reverse-flash from
season 1 so that's the version of
Harrison wells that he was talking about
if it wasn't clear but he also says that
he was in contact with Louise Lincoln
who's another version of killer frost
from the comic the costume the Caitlyn
wore during season 3 is inspired by
Louise Lincoln's costume but then he
also says that he's been in contact with
Victor freeze meaning that mr. freeze
exists in earth 1 so obviously big
Batman villain and this more
foreshadowing for the Batwoman crossover
when they go to gotham city 7 the
version of his origin story that he
explains is icicles origin story and
icicle jr. what happened is is the
original version of icicle debuted in
1947 during the Golden Age of comics he
used a cold gun he used it so much that
it modified his DNA and when his son was
born icicle jr. he was born with ice
based powers and didn't need to use a
gun so they're kind of doing the icicle
icicle jr. origin story with these
characters but her father explains that
the cryostasis treatment that he was
giving himself was what created this
alternate person although he's lying
about the alternate personality it does
the same thing to killer frost when he
treated her with a slightly modified
version of his serum that's what created
the alternate personality the killer
frost side of herself brief interlude
first cicada who shows up at the
hospital all messed up but he
understands that he's getting more
powerful so that's why he tells the
woman not to heal him at the end it's
making me stronger in the teaser for
next week's episode they're
foreshadowing a really big battle
between team flash in cicada like I said
episode 8 the anniversary episode the
premise that causes them to go back in
time is something they need to fight
cicada so even though he's supposed to
be kind of the main villain he's kind of
been a backburner storyline for now but
I think starting with next week's
episode they're focusing on the
character a little bit more 5 they have
Nora try out a couple new flash powers
when they're trying to find the core of
that dark matter satellite she needed to
find it at the bottom of that body of
water so after they go back and forth on
how best
run on water and use that special
ability what they're doing though is
they're referencing something that was
referencing something else so it gets
kind of meta because they reference iris
running on water last season when she
was trying to move that tidal wave
around but that in and of itself was a
reference to Barry back during season
one when he was stopping the tidal wave
during the weather wizard episode so
it's a reference of a reference I'm sure
like as many more seasons as the flash
goes on they'll continue to do stuff
like that where a character tries to do
something from a previous season that
was a reference itself to something from
much much earlier for pretty WTF Cisco
figures out that icicle has been wearing
a human skin suit this whole time
using stem cells so it's very Silence of
the Lambs just walking around in a human
skin suit to hide his frost form because
he like he shows his skin he looks like
that all the time I think they wanted to
make it look a little more natural on
the actor because in the comics he's
like a full-blown walking living icicle
they confront him he shows his true face
takes them down immediately and you
start to see the beginnings of killer
frost come back with several more ice
puns pretty much from here on out is all
ice puns three icicle versus team flash
he takes them out immediately just by
lowering the temperature in the room
remember they did this during season
three when Barry was battling killer
frost after she had teamed up with
saboteur so the whole thing with killer
frost powers is that she actually sucks
the energy the heat energy out of things
this way the flash can actually make her
more powerful they didn't use it that
way in this instant but if she needed to
charge herself up she could just suck
heat energy out of either Nora or Barry
as long as they were generating
lightning they actually used that for a
little bit of comedy later too when
Barry shocks Cisco so that he'll warm up
a little bit faster but number two
obviously this is all building towards a
killer frost versus icicle fight and you
actually learned that icicle cares about
killer frost as if he's her true
daughter we get to be ourselves so
they're just trying to put more of a
character behind icicle instead of just
making him a mustache twirling villain
she finally figures out how to bring
killer frost back takes him down so now
we have killer frost back the way they
do her makeup and this outfit actually
looks pretty good too I don't know if
they're gonna give her a brand new
costume or if it'll just be like this
for the rest of the season but the way
they leave things at the end of the
episode implies that she'll start using
her powers more and more slowly as we
get closer
to the end of the season so probably by
the season finale she'll have fully
learned how to bring her out at will
number one though really cool twist they
actually used the mental dampener to
allow Caitlin and killer frost to talk
to each other so the way you hear killer
frost talking in her head like it's a
voiceover hey we got a lot to talk about
just expect them to have some fun with
that in future episodes so like if
Caitlin is having to talk to Ralph and
he's saying something really douchey you
can have killer frost doing a Deadpool
style commentary track just making fun
of him and only Caitlin will be able to
hear it so I'm sure they'll use that for
some comedy in future episodes but when
they found that dark matter satellite
and hold it in to STAR Labs there was an
interesting reference that they made
when they said that they were narrowing
down on cicadas location they said that
they found two twins that had lost their
father and I'm like is that supposed to
be a tornado twins reference because
they're talking about dark matter
satellite a lightning-shaped dagger that
looks like it gives off negative Speed
Force energy like they just haven't
fully explained where they're going with
this storyline ultimately so everybody
wants tornado twins it just feels like
they might find a way to reference them
somehow
on the TV show all the Icicle stuff
during the episode was great but I think
they handed up a little too much with
Cecile I think they tried to go way too
over-the-top and obviously all this
Sherlock Wells stuff but that's kind of
been a thing this entire season even
Cisco was making fun of his lame accent
during the episode so everybody just let
me know if he spotted any Easter eggs
that I didn't mention in the video
like I said ice puns from everyone over
9000 it was crazy I'll do a trailer
video for next week's episode tomorrow
morning obviously is Thanksgiving week
they'll probably be a whole bunch other
trailers dropping for the crossover so
I'll just post everything as soon as it
drops no worries congratulations
Victoria yo you're the giveaway winner
from my last big DC video please email
me on the about page of my channel so I
can get your contact details click here
to learn what's going on with the
Avengers 4 trailer and the new official
Marvel MCU timeline and click here for
that last big flash Batman Batwoman
crossover trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
you
[Music]